net migration to the United Kingdom is
far too high that was already clear from
the previous set of official data the
ons have today amended their previous
published estimate of net migration for
the year ending June 2022 to 606 000.
the statistics published today indicate
that net migration has flatlined since
then
in the year ending December 2022 they
estimate that net migration remains at
606 000. these particularly High figures
are in large part due to Temporary and
exceptional factors such as the UK's
Ukraine and Hong Kong bno schemes
the government remains committed to
reducing overall net migration to
sustainable levels that is a solemn
promise we made to the British public in
our Manifesto and we are unwavering in
our determination to deliver it
this week we announced steps to tackle
the substantial rise in the number of
student dependents coming to the UK the
package of measures will ensure that we
can reduce migration whilst continuing
to benefit from the skills and resources
our economy needs because universities
should be in the education business not
the immigration business
we expect this package to have a
tangible impact on net migration taken
together with the easing of temporary
factors like our exceptional
humanitarian offers we expect net
migration to fall to pre-pandemic levels
in the medium term
Mr Speaker the public rightly expect us
to control our borders whether that is
stopping the boats and addressing
illegal migration or whether it's
ensuring levels of legal migration do
not Place undue pressure on public
services on housing Supply or
integration the government is taking
decisive action on both counts under the
points-based system we introduced post
brexit we can control immigration we
must control immigration and we will
thank you Mr Speaker today's
extraordinary figures including doubling
the number of work visas since the
pandemic show that the conservatives
have no plan and no grip on immigration
they show the chaos in this government
work visas are 119 since before the
pandemic conservatives have totally
failed to tackle endemic skills
shortages and get people back to work
net migration is more than twice the
level that ministers were aiming for and
considerably more than that compared to
the home secretaries claimed aims the
Asylum backlog is at a record high the
opposite of the prime minister's promise
to clear the backlog this year and less
than one percent of last year's small
boat arrivals have had a decision yet
where is the Home Secretary who is in
charge of these policies she's gone to
ground there are reports she's not even
going to do media she's not come to this
house she's in internal meetings
presumably more private courses arranged
by the civil servants what is the point
of her net migration should come down
and we would expect it to do so